[संगीत]
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग टू ल तो एक बार आप
सब लोग यह बता दीजिए सबको मेरी आवाज आ रही
है नहीं आ रही वो कंफर्म कर
दीजिए चैट में बता दीजिए कि य स या
नो
चलो ओके थैंक यू तो वेलकम टू डे 12 ऑफ दिस
बेस्ट मास्टरी कोर्स
और आज से हम कुछ नया स्टार्ट करने वाले
हैं काफी प्रैक्टिकल चलेगा और काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग रहेगा धीरे-धीरे क्या है आप
आपकी स्क्रिप्ट लिखना सीखो जने आपकी
स्क्रिप्टिंग कैसे की जाती है कैसे आप
अपने स्क्रिप्ट लिख सकते हो खुल से लॉजिक
लगा लगा के वो लिखना सीखो धीरे-धीरे टॉपिक
वाइज टॉपिक इसमें भी टॉपिक्स रहेंगे लेकिन
टॉपिक के अकॉर्डिंग हम धीरे-धीरे हम अपने
स्क्रिप्ट बिल्डिंग प काम करना शुरू
करेंगे थ्योरी भी रहेगा थोड़ा सा क्योंकि
आपका बेसिक नॉलेज जरूरी है बट मोस्टली
प्रैक्टिकल रहेगा तो जो आज हम डिस्कस करने
वाले हैं वह चीजें है
आपकी यह
रहा य आज जो हम पढ़ने वाले हैं बेसिकली हम
पोजीशनल पैरामीटर्स के बारे में पढ़ेंगे
और दूसरा जो हम पढ़ने वाले हैं हम पढ़ने
वाले हैं आपका पोज पैरामीटर प्लस में जो
हम पढ़ने वाले य स्क्रीन पर चलता हूं सबसे
पहले हम पढ़ने वाले हैं हम एक तो
है
पोजीशनल
पैरामीटर पैरामीटर्स और दूसरा टॉपिक हम
पढ़ने वाले हैं सबसे पहला तो यह हमारा
फर्स्ट
टॉपिक टॉपिक वन जो हमारा रहेगा यह सेकंड
टॉपिक हम पढ़ने वाले हैं वह हमारा रहेगा
टॉपिक टू स्पेशल पैरामीटर्स स्पेशल
पैरामीटर टॉपिक टू जो हमारा रहेगा व का
स्पेशल
पैरामीटर्स
स्पेशल पैरामीटर्स ये दोनों चीज होती क्या
है कैसे यूज करते इसके बारे में पढ़ने
वाले हैं बेसिकली और उससे ज्यादा और कुछ
नहीं है और काफी इजी कांसेप्ट है आपका कुछ
भी हार्ड एंड फास्ट नहीं है तो हम पढ़ने
वाले हैं सबसे पहले पोजीशन पैरामीटर्स के
बारे में देखो अभी तक मैं एक चीज बताता
आया आपको कि जो भी आप कमांड अपने स्क्रीन
पर लिखते हो उसमें सबसे पहले कमांड होती
है उसके बाद आर्गुमेंट होते हैं तो वह चीज
एक अपने आप में कुछ लॉजिक है इसलिए बारबार
उसको चीज को बताया जाता है तो उसको
बताऊंगा नहीं दोबारा तो एक चीज है आप
लोगों ने नोटिस किया होगा आपने बहुत सारे
टूल्स यूज किए होंगे टूल्स के साथ आप क्या
करते हैं बहुत सारे ऑप्शंस का यूज करते
हैं या बहुत सारे फ्लैग्स का यूज करते हैं
हाई फन यू आउटपुट सेव करने के लिए या हान
अगर एन मैप यूज किया तो उसके साथ भी आप
हान एसवी हान पीएन तो हान हान स्क्रिप्ट
बहुत सारे टूल्स
का बहुत सारे टूल्स का क्या करते है आप
बहुत सारे टूल्स यूज किए आपने और वहां पर
क्या इस तरीके से यूज करते हो और उनके कुछ
ना कुछ फ्लैग्स होते हैं कुछ ना कुछ ऑप्शन
होते हैं तो कभी आप लोगों ने अगर सोचा
होगा अगर दिमाग में नहीं आया होगा तो आना
चाहिए कि ठीक है हम हमें पता है कि जो
फर्स्ट लाइन है जो स्क्रिप्ट स्क्रिप्ट जब
रन करते हैं तो उसका जो फर्स्ट वर्ड है वो
कमांड है उसके अलावा जो कमांड लाइन
आर्गुमेंट है वे ऑप्शंस है और वो ऑप्शंस
आपकी जो स्क्रिप्ट है वो कैसे पता चलता है
कि उस ऑप्शन की वैल्यू ये है उस तो लॉजिक
रहा होगा कि उसको पता चलता है कि जो कमांड
लाइन आर्गुमेंट है य पहले पे दूसरे प
तीसरे पर चौथे पर उसको कैसे ना कैसे तो
पता चलता उसके ऊपर यूजर्स ने यह वैल्यू दी
है और मुझे यह टास्क परफॉर्म करना है कुछ
ना कुछ तो लॉजिक है वो चीज पॉसिबल हो पाती
है पोजीशनल पैरामीटर्स की हेल्प से उस चीज
को समझने के लिए या उस चीज को जानने के
लिए कि वो कैसे पता चला आपकी स्क्रिप्ट
स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर कि इस पर्टिकुलर कमांड
लाइन आर्गुमेंट पे क्या वैल्यू है
वो पॉसिबल हो पाए किसकी हेल्प से
पोजीशनल पैरामीटर्स की हेल्प से बेसिकली
क्या होता है कि जितने भी जो कमांड लाइन
आर्गुमेंट होते हैं जो स्पेस सेपरेटेड
जितने भी आप कमांड लाइन आर्गुमेंट
प्रोवाइड करते हो आप अपनी स्क्रिप्ट को हर
एक को सेल क्या करता है एक नंबर साइन कर
देता है हर एक को सेल क्या कर देता है एक
नंबर असाइन कर देता है अगर मैं लिख देता
हूं आपके सामने लिख देता हूं स्क्रीन पर
कि टी आई ओ
एन मैं लिख देता
हूं की द
सेल
असाइन असाइन ए
नंबर नंबर्स
कॉल्ड पोजीशनल प पोजीशनल
पैरामीटर्स पोजीशनल पैरामीटर टू
ईच कमांड लाइनस ईच कमांड लाइन आर्गुमेंट
आर्गू एम एटी आर्गू मेंट्स दैट इज
एंटर्ड जितने भी कमांड लाइन आर्गुमेंट आप
क्या करते हो एंटर करते हो अपनी स्क्रीन
के ऊपर सबको आपका सेल क्या करता है एक
नंबर असाइन कर देता है जिसको हम बोलते हैं
पोजीशनल पैरामीटर जिसको हम बोलते हैं
पोजीशन प फॉर एग्जांपल मैं आपको एग्जांपल
शो करूं तो एग्जांपल है मेरा कि कमेंट में
फॉर एग्जांपल
फर एग्जांपल अगर मैं लिखता हूं यह मेरा
एग्जांपल रहेगा आपके सामने एग्जांपल में
मेरा मैं लिखा य पर डॉलर या मैं क्या करता
हूं य डॉलर नहीं य पर लिखा मैंने
आवर स्क्रिप्ट स्क्रिप्ट नेम प स्क्रिप्ट
का नाम हो गया उसके बाद स्पेस सेपरेटेड
आर्गुमेंट देते हैं फर एपल मैंने नाम लिखा
जो सचिन देन उसके बाद मैंने लिखा डॉलर होम
तो सेल ने क्या किया यह फर्स्ट तो आपका
क्या है ओके मैं इसको हाईलाइट नहीं कर
सकता फर्स्ट में आवर स्क्रिप्ट नेम क्या
है ये तो एक क्या है आपका कमांड होगी उसके
बाद जो कमांड ला आर्गुमेंट है सचिन और
डॉलर होम इनको क्या कर दिया उसने नंबर
असाइन कर दिया इसको बोला सचिन को वन इसको
टू अगर इसके पास जितने भी आप आर्गुमेंट
लिखोगे उसके थ्री उसके बाद फोर 5 6 7 8 एज
ऑन यज आपकी मर्जी कितने भी तो उन सबको सेल
ने ऑटोमेटिक क्या नंबर साइन कर दिया जिसको
हम पोजीशन पैरामीटर्स बोलते हैं फर एपल
स्क्रिप्ट आपको एपल लाइव एग्जांपल दिखाता
हूं आपको कट करके आपको क्या दिखाता लाइव
एग्जांपल हम क्या करते है नो अभी मैं
डायरेक्ट मैं स्क्रिप्ट करता हूं प ओ एस
आई टी आई ओ एन पोजीशनल
स्क्रिप्ट स्क्रिप्ट ड
एने ट एटर अब मैं क्या लान य पर मेंशन
करूंगा स ला सबको पता है क्या होती है हम
क्यों मेंशन करते हैं बताने की जरूरत नहीं
है बिन और बैस बिन और बैस
विन और ओके आईम सॉरी फॉर ट
चलो
ओके चलो यह शायद आपको अभी स्कन जूम कर
दिया मैंने आपको अच्छे से दिखाई दे रहा
होगा अगर थोड़ा सा और बोलेंगे थोड़ा सा और
कर देता हूं मैं यहा चलो बन और बेस मैंने
क्या कि मेंशन किया उसके बाद मैंने लिखा
फर एपल मैं करता हूं
एकको सबसे इजी वे है अपने आउटपुट को देखने
का कि आप जो काम कर रहे हो उसको एक बार
देख पा उसके बाद स्क्रिप्ट लिखोगे एक किया
मैंने प उसके बाद लिखा माय नेम इज और जोय
पोजीशन पैरामीटर्स है उनको क्या कर दिया
एक नंबर असाइन कर दिया टूथ 4 करके और आपको
पता है किसी भी पैरामीटर्स की वैल्यू को
अगर आपको देखना हो या उसकी वैल्यू को
रेफरेंस करना तो आप यूज करते हो पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन तो उसके लिए आप डॉलर सिंबल उसके
बाद वन उसके बाद क्या लिखा मैंने वन देन
उसके बाद मैंने क्या किया फिर से एकको
उसके बाद लिखा मैंने
देन माय होम
डायरेक्टरी माय होम डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
माय
फेवरेट
कलर कलर
इज डलर 3 डलर 3 अब मैंने मैं क्या चाहता
हूं कि यहां पर वैल्यू ऑटोमेटिक आ जाए य
आपके उससे कमांड लाइन आर्गुमेंट से यहां
पर अपने आप आ जाए यहां पर भी अपने आप आ
जाए उसके बाद कंट्रोल एस कंट्रोल एक्स
मैंने कर दिया अब इसको परमिशन देनी होगी
सीच मोड देन उसके बाद परमिशन दूंगा 744
इसका नाम रहेगा हमारा पोजीशनल रो ओके
नेक्स्ट इसको रन करता हूं अब मैं इसको
लिखूंगा ज पोजीशन ड एस एच पीओ एस आई टी
पोजीशन डट एस एच एक बार मैं क्या करता हूं
रुको एक
मि आपको सही से क्लियर आ
जाए ओ हो हो हो
ओके ल सी यार ओके क्लियर कर देता हूं
स्क्रीन एक बार आपके सामने देन मैं क्या
करता हूं
ये पोजीशनल डट ए उसके बाद मुझे क्या करना
पड़ेगा उसके बाद मुझे क्या देना पड़ेगा
आर्गुमेंट देने होंगे फॉर एग्जांपल मैंने
नाम लिखा सचिन देन उसके बाद कन साप डॉलर
होम डॉलर होम उसके बाद मैंने क्या लिखा
नेक्स्ट मैंने लिखा कलर कलर लिखा मैंने
रेड रेड मैं लिखा और हिट एंटर कर दिया अभी
देखो आपकी जो स्क्रिप्ट ने ऑटोमेटिक जो भी
आपको पता है अभी तक जितने भी आप टूल रन
करते थे वहां पर जो भी आप फ्लैग मेंशन
करते थे या जो भी आप
स्पेस सेपरेट आर्गुमेंट उसके बेसिस प आपको
रिजल्ट मिलता था ये सेम वही काम कर रहा है
मे स्क्रिप्ट है ये मेरा टूल है उसको
मैंने इसको ऑप्शन प्रोवाइड किए अब इसने
स्क्रिप्ट में इस ऑप्शन के बेसिस पर जो
आउटपुट शो करना था या जो टास्क परफॉर्म
करना था वो परफॉर्म कर रहा है देखो यहां
पर ये डॉलर वन यहां से इसकी वैल्यू को फैच
किया डॉलर टू आर्गुमेंट पे कौन सा है ये
रहा पोजीशन पैरामीटर्स पे कौन सा है उसकी
वैल्यू क्या है डॉलर होम डॉलर होम में
क्या है होम ड होम और काली र उसकी वैल्यू
यहां पर आ गई उसके बाद रेड यहां पर लिख
दिया मैं रेड उसके बाद जो डॉलर थ पर क्या
है आपका का जो थर्ड पोजीशन पैरामीटर है
उसका जो थर्ड कमांड लाइन आर्गुमेंट की जो
वैल्यू है वो रेड है इस तरीके से क्या है
आपका जो स्क्रिप्ट है आपकी कमांड लाइन
आर्गुमेंट की वैल्यू को रीड करती है इस
इसके बाद हम चलते हैं और इसमें और भी
एग्जांपल देखने वाले हैं
हम अभी एक चीज देखिए कि हमें यहां पर एक
चीज समझने की बात यह है कि देखो यहां पर
हम क्या कर रहे हैं कि यूजर डिफाइंड
वेरिएबल क्रिएट करने की वजह सेल क्या कर
रहा है इन पैरामीटर्स को हमारे लिए ो
टिकली डिफाइन कर रहा है हमें इस पैरामीटर
को कहीं पर भी डिफाइन करने की जरूरत नहीं
है इनकी टेक केयर भी ऑटोमेटिक सेल ही करता
है आपको सिंपली क्या करना है कमांड लाइन
आर्गुमेंट देखना है कमांड लाइन आर्गुमेंट
में वैल्यू देनी है स्पेस एप उसको क्या कर
रहा है पोजीशनल पैरामीटर्स की हेल्प से
आपका जो सेल है ऑटोमेटिक उसको हैंडल कर
रहा है आपको कोई भी यूजर डिफाइंड वेरिएबल
डिफाइन करने की जरूरत नहीं है बस सिंपली
आपको वैल्यू एंटर करनी है बाकी सब कुछ
किसपे छोड़ देना है सेल के ऊपर बस उसके
बाद आपको क्या करना है वैल्यू को फैच करने
के लिए उस पैरामीटर को आपको यूज़ करना है
और ऊपर से क्या है दूसरी चीज क्या है कि
सेल ने इनको न्यूमेरिकल वैल्यू में रखा है
और यह रिजर्व भी है और आप अगर आप चाहो भी
तो इनकी वैल्यू को मैनुअली चेंज नहीं कर
सकते इसके अंदर कोई भी वैल्यू आप डिफाइन
नहीं कर सकते अगर आपको लगता कि आप डिफाइन
कर सकते हो मैंने लिखा डॉलर व अगर
डॉलर वन इक्वल टू अगर मैं लिखता हूं यहां
पर मैंने लिखा जोनी देन इट देखो कमांड नॉट
फाउट क्योंकि जो यह वैल्यू है ये रिजर्व
वर्ड्स है इसके अंदर कोई भी वैल्यू आप
डिफाइन भी नहीं कर सकते नेक्स्ट सवाल आप
लोगों का होगा कि सर मैं ये जो पोजीशन
पैरामीटर्स है
सर ये जो पोजीशनल पैरामीटर्स है आपको
दिखाई दे रहे हैं सर ये कितने दे सकता हूं
अपने स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर इनकी कोई लिमिट है
क्या मैं इनको दो ही दे सकता हूं तीन दे
सकता हूं 10 दे सकता हूं 100 दे सकता हूं
कितने दे सकता हूं देखो इनकी कोई भी लिमिट
नहीं है आप आपकी जितनी रिक्वा
रिक्वायरमेंट आपकी स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर उतनी
आप दे सकते हो इनकी कोई भी लिमिट नहीं है
तो यह आपके सवाल का जवाब था फॉर एग्जांपल
मैं क्या करता हूं हां एक चीज आपको ध्यान
देने की जरूरत है कि अगर आपको जो
पैरामीटर्स जो पोजीशन पैरामीटर्स है अगर
जो कमांड लाइंड आर्गुमेंट है अगर वो डबल
डिजिट वाली में जा रहे है मतलब नाइन के
बाद 10 11 12 13 उनकी वैल्यू को कैसे आपको
क्या करना है रीड करना है उसकी वैल्यू
कैसे रेफरेंस लेना है वो मैं अभी आपको
सिखाता हूं तो फिर हम अपने स्क्रिप्ट के
अंदर चलते हैं ये रहा न हो गया अभी तक हम
क्या कर रहे थे एकको डलर व डॉलर टू डलर थ
अगर मुझे डबल डिजिट वाली वैल्यू को क्या
करना है अगर मुझे देखना है तो मैं एक को
करूंगा उसके बाद मैं लिखता
हूं मैं लिखा
द थ उसके बाद आर्गुमेंट
द 10थ आर्गुमेंट
इज उसके बाद डॉलर कर्ली ब्रेसस देन उसके
बाद मुझे यहां पर लि नंबर 10 मैं ऐसे
करूंगा अगर मैं डायरेक्टली लिख दूंगा तो
आपको
इसका वो भी दिखाता हूं कि क्या प्रॉब्लम
होगी आपको इसके बाद में लिखा द
11थ आर्गुमेंट
आर्गुमेंट इज और मैंने लिखा डॉलर
डायरेक्टली अगर मैंने ऐसे लिख दिया डॉलर
एक मिनट
डलर अगर आप ऐसा लिखोगे डबल डिजिट वैल्यू
को तो क्या आपका आउटपुट आएगा कंट्रोल एस
वो भी आपको दिखाता हूं मैं ये रहा अभी
मुझे क्या करना है इसके अंदर वैल्यू देनी
होगी तो वैल्यू देने के लिए उसके बाद मैं
क्या करता हूं 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 ना कितने हो गए 9 10 11 12 13 मुझे क्या
करना है 7 3 10 और 8 इतने आर्गुमेंट दे
दिए मैंने अब यहां पर कितने हो गए न ट 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 ट एंटर कर दिया मैंने अभी
देखो यहां पर माय नेम सचिन ओके इसकी
वैल्यू सही ले लिया इसने इसकी वैल्यू को
सही लिया थर्ड वाली वैल्यू को सही लिया
उसके बाद जो थ आर्गुमेंट की वैल्यू थी 10
आर्गुमेंट क्या था आपका से था ना ये 10
इसकी वैल्यू सही लिया लेकिन जब थ
आर्गुमेंट आपने किया जो आपने 11 खा इसने
क्या कर दिया सचिन ले लिया उसके बाद वन
लिख दिया क्योंकि भैया उसने समझ में नहीं
आया उसे समझा कि डॉलर वन की वैल्यू रखनी
उसके बाद ये एक्स्ट्रा में है इसलिए आपको
आपको अगर आप देखोगे ये रहा इसलिए इस तरीके
से आपको डबल डिजिट वैल्यू को क्या करना है
रेफरेंस लेना है इस तरीके से रेफरेंस लेगे
तो आपका जो आउटपुट है जो चाहोगे वैसा नहीं
क्योंकि इसने स्टार्टिंग में डॉलर वन तो
सही समझा उसके बाद इसे लगा कि य इसके साथ
अटैच करना है ओके तो यह आपकी बात को समझ
नहीं पाए यहां पर यह था आपका कौन सा
पोजीशनल पैरामीटर्स के बारे में और अब मैं
एक काम करता हूं आपको पोजीशन पैरामीटर के
बेस पर एक असाइनमेंट करके दिखाता हूं कि
आपको और भी ज्यादा रियलिस्टिक एग्जांपल
मिलेगा आपको समझ में भी आएगा तो हम चलते
हैं तो हम रियलिस्टिक एग्जांपल प चलते हैं
देखो यह रहा रिस्टिक एग्जांपल ये रहा अभी
मुझे क्या करना है एक असाइनमेंट करना है
पोजीशन पैरामीटर के ऊपर आपको असाइनमेंट
में क्या है क्रिएट ए बेस स्क्रिप्ट आपको
एक बैक बैस की स्क्रिप्ट क्रिएट करनी है
दैट विल सर्व एज ए बेसिक कैलकुलेटर एंड
अलाउ यू टू परफॉर्म सिंपल अर्थमेटिक
कैलकुलेशन फ्रॉम द कमांड लाइन अगर मैं
आपको नहीं दिखा तो मैं आपको जूम कर देता
हूं आपको बेसिकली क्या करना है कि एक
स्क्रिप्ट लिखनी है कैलकुलेटर बेसिक
कैलकुलेटर स्क्रिप्ट आपको परफॉर्म करनी है
जिसमें आप क्या करोगे अर्थमेटिक कैलकुलेशन
करोगे जिसके अंदर वो भी कमांड लाइन के
थ्रू देन पहली क पहली चीज तो ये है आपको
स्क्रिप्ट बनानी है कैलकुलेटर स्किप है
उसके बाद अर्थमेटिक कैलकुलेशन करनी है
ओबवियसली नेक्स्ट है द कैलकुलेटर नीड्स टू
बी एबल टू एडिशन सबक्स मल्टीप्लिकेशन
डिवीजन ऑन ए मैक्सिमम नाइन नंबर्स अभी
क्या है कि हम कोई हाईफाई स्क्रिप्ट तो
लिख नहीं रहे हैं बस एक बेसिक स्क्रिप्ट
आपकी प्रैक्टिस के लिए लिख रहे हैं कोई
हाई लेवल कोड नहीं लिख रहे ताकि आप लोगों
को पता चल जाए कि आपको लॉजिक क्या-क्या
सोच के कैसे क्याक लिखना है वो आपको बस
धीरे-धीरे प्रैक्टिस में आ जाएगा तो आपको
क्या करना है कि इसमें एडिशन भी सबक्स
मल्टीप्लिकेशन डिवीजन आप कुछ भी कर सकते
हो उसके बाद ओनली मैक्सिमम नाइन नंबर्स के
ऊपर करना है जीरो से लेकर नाइन तक ओके तो
इसने बोला कि आप आपके सामने कंडीशन है कि
जो फर्स्ट कमांड लाइन आर्गुमेंट होगा जो
फर्स्ट कमांड लाइन आर्गुमेंट होगा गिवन टू
द स्क्रिप्ट विल कंटेन द ऑपरेशन फर्स्ट
लाइन कमांड आर्गुमेंट में आपको क्या करना
है ऑपरेशन परफॉर्म करवाना ओनली ऑपरेशन
देना कि आप एडिशन करवाना चाहते हो सबक्स
करवाना चाहते हो मल्टी लेशन करवाना चाहते
हो या डिवीजन करवाना चाहते हो दैट इज टू
बी परफॉर्म ऑन द नंबर जो उस नंबर्स के ऊपर
परफॉर्म किया जाए आइर या तो सबक्स हो
चाहिए एडिशन अभी के लिए हम क्या सबक्स और
एडिशन रखना चाहते हैं द ऑपरेशन चोजन विल
बी अप्लाइड टू ऑल नंबर्स सभी नंबर्स के
ऊपर इसको अप्लाई किया जाए फॉर एग्जांपल
कैसे कि अगर फर्स्ट कमांड लाइन आर्गुमेंट
आपने प्लस लिया है तो जो सारे के सारे जो
अदर कमांड लाइन आर्गुमेंट होंगे सेकंड से
लेकर 10 तक क्योंकि हमें नौ नंबर तक लेना
है ना नौ नंबर तक विल बी एडेड टूगेदर उनको
ऐड कर दिया जाएगा एक साथ यदि आपने सबट
क्शन लिया है तो देन ऑल द अदर कमांड लाइन
आर्गुमेंट विल बी सबट क्टेड फ्रॉम ईच अदर
एंड सो ऑन इस तरीके से अब उसके बाद इसने
लिखा यर स्क्रिप्ट नीड टू बी एबल टू
एक्सेप्ट द ऑपरेशन एज द फर्स्ट कमांड लाइन
आर्गुमेंट एंड आल्सो एक्सेप्ट अप टू नाइन
नंबर्स फॉर टोटल 10 कमांड लाइन आर्गुमेंट
अभी यहां पर क्या है कि हर चीज के साथ
लिमिट लिमिट के साथ आपको करवा रहा है कि
आपको क्या करना है फर्स्ट कमांड लाइन
आर्गू मेंट्स ऑपरेशन की होनी चाहिए नाइन
नंबर तक आपको एक्सेप्ट करना चाहिए उसके
बाद टोटल आपको 10 कमांड लाइन आर्गुमेंट ही
रख रहे हैं इससे ज्यादा इसके अंदर आपको
रखने नहीं है वैसे तो कैलकुलेशन स्क्रिप्ट
में कितने भी हो सकते है लेकिन हम क्या है
10 तक रख रहे हैं तो ओके हम अपने
स्क्रिप्ट को अभी क्या करें लिखते हैं तो
अभी आपको समझना है कि स्क्रिप्टिंग को
लिखना है तो बेसिकली आपको किसी भी प्रकार
की आप स्क्रिप्ट लिखो या किसी भी प्रकार
का कोई भी कोड लिखो प्रोग्राम लिखो कुछ भी
लिखते हो तो बेसिकली आपको वहां पर कुछ
चीजों को ध्यान में रखना होता है य आपको
समझना होता है कि पहली बात तो आपको क्या
टास्क परफॉर्म करना है और आपको को हर चीज
के ऊपर सोचना होता है कि ओके इस पर मुझे
परमिशन क्या रखनी है स्क्रिप्ट के केस में
उसके बाद इसके अंदर क्या मुझे लॉजिस लगाने
हैं क्या-क्या यूजर्स दे सकता है वो सारी
चीजें आपको समझना होगा उसके बाद का
स्क्रिप्ट आपसे क्या चाहती है वो सारी
चीजें आपको समझ समझनी होगी अभी मैं क्या
करता हूं ननो उसके बाद हम रखते हैं
स्क्रिप्ट का नाम सील ड एसए कैलकुलेटर सी
ए एल सी यू सी यू एल ए टी ओ आर कैलकुलेटर
ड एसस स्क्रिप्ट का नाम मैंने रखा देन हिट
एंटर किया फ सबसे पहले हम लाइन यूज करेंगे
सी बैंग लाइन सी बैंग लाइन स्ल बिन स्ल
बैस सबसे पहले हम ये यूज करेंगे देन उसके
बाद मुझे क्या करना है अभी मुझे सबसे पहले
आपको एक पहली कंडीशन क्या है आपके
स्क्रिप्ट के लिए कि आपका जो फर्स्ट
पोजीशनल पैरामीटर होगा व आपका होना चाहिए
ऑपरेटर या तो प्लस होना चाहिए माइनस होना
चाहिए सक्शन और एडिशन के लिए दूसरा जो
पोजीशन पैरामीटर्स रहेंगे सेकंड से लेकर
10 तक वो नाइन नंबर्स तक ही होंगे जीरो से
नान तक कुछ भी हो सकता है उसके बाद हम
उनके ऊपर क्या करना चाहते हैं कैलकुलेशन
परफॉर्म करना क्योंकि हम टोटल 10
आर्गुमेंट ही देना चाहते हैं टोटल उस
ऑपरेशन को 10 आर्गुमेंट ही देना चाहते हैं
यह भी लिमिट हम बाउंड कर रहे हैं तो वो हम
कैसे देंगे उसके बाद देखो एक चीज बताओ अभी
आप लोग दिमाग में चीज आ रहा ठीक है फर्स्ट
पोजीशन पैरामीटर्स प आप दे दोगे ऑपरेटर दे
दोगे उसके बाद बाकी पोजीशन पैरामीटर्स भी
आप डिफाइन कर लोगे अपने स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर
लेकिन आपको एक चीज सोचो कि किसी यूजर्स ने
यहां पर अगर एमटी दे दिया तो वो लॉजिक में
तो आपने रखना कि अगर किसी भी यूजर्स ने
उसके अंदर आपकी स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर कुछ भी
डिफाइन नहीं किया फ कोई भी ऑप्शन ऑप्शन
डिफाइन नहीं किया या आपके यूजर्स
ने क्या किया ऑपरेटर यूज कर लिया उसके बाद
फर्स्ट कमांड लाइन आर्गुमेंट यूज किया
नेक्स्ट कमांड लाइन आर्गुमेंट यूज ही नहीं
किया उसको एमटी छोड़ दिया तो भैया उसका भी
तो सलूशन निकालना होगा ना ऐसा तो कि एमटी
के ऊपर कैलकुलेशन कभी परफॉर्म होती है
क्या कभी भी परफॉर्म नहीं हो होती तो उसके
लिए आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा एक प्री
डिफाइंड वैल्यू डिफाइन करके रखनी पड़ेगी
हमेशा आप क्या करते हो खासकर कैलकुलेशन हो
या कई बार कोई भी प्रोग्राम्स लिखते हो तो
आप एक प्री डिफाइंड वैल्यू हमेशा उसकी
डिफाइन करके रखते हो फॉर एग्जांपल अगर
यूजर किसी भी वजह से उसके अंदर उसने
ऑप्शंस या आर्गुमेंट नहीं दिया यूजर इनपुट
नहीं दिया या हो सकता है कि वो देने वाला
था कुछ प्रॉब्लम हुई तो बाय डिफॉल्ट एक
ऐसी वैल्यू होती है वो वैल्यू आप डिसाइड
कर सकते हो एज पर योर प्रोग्राम वो वैल्यू
ऑटोमेटिक उसको ज्यादा इफेक्ट ना करते हुए
बाय डिफॉल्ट सेटिंग के साथ रन कर जाए इसी
प्रकार से हम भी क्या करेंगे बाय डिफॉल्ट
वो वैल्यू रखेंगे तो सबसे सि बैंग लाइन
हमने मेंशन कर दी और यहां पर मैं एकको का
यूज करने वाला हूं अब एक सिंटेक्स बताता
हूं आपको मैं कमेंट करके यहां पर कमेंट ये
है जो हम सिंटेक्स यूज करने वाले हैं इसके
लिए सिंटेक्स फॉर
आवर सिंटेक्स फॉर आवर सेफ्टी मैकेनिज्म एस
ए एफ ई टी सेफ्टी सी एच ए ए सेफ्टी
मैकेनिज्म सेफ्टी मैकेनिज्म जो सिंटेक्स
हम यूज करने वाले हैं किसके लिए क्योंकि
हम तो परफॉर्म तो बेसिकली हम पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन ही परफॉर्म करने वाले हैं तो
पैरामीटर एक्सपेंस आप कैसे यूज कर सकते हो
मैं आपको बताता हूं आप डॉलर तो यूज करोगे
ही करोगे आप क्या करोगे डॉलर यूज करोगे
उसके बाद कली ब्रेसस करोगे इसके अंदर आप
मेंशन करते हो क्या पैरामीटर पैरामीटर की
वैल्यू देते हो तो अगर इसके अंदर एक ऑप्शन
यूज कर सकते हैं हम कॉलन उसके बाद माइनस
देन उसके बाद यहां पर लिखते हो आप डब्लू
माइनस और यहां पर क्या मा सकते हो वर्ड
वर्ड वर्ड में आप क्या करते हो प्री
डिफाइंड वैल्यू माइनस नहीं डैश ही है यहां
पर आप क्या करते हो प्री डिफाइंड वैल्यू
डिफाइन करते हो इस पैरामीटर वैल्यू के लिए
फॉर एग्जांपल अगर ये पैरामीटर एमटी है इस
पैरामीटर को कुछ भी वैल्यू नहीं दी तो ये
जो प्री डिफाइंड वैल्यू होगी ये ऑटोमेटिक
इसके अंदर स्टोर होगी फैच होगी रेफरेंस
लेगी और उसके बेस पर आपका टास्क परफॉर्म
किया जाएगा तो अब हम स्क्रिप्ट को कैसे
क्रिएट कर सकते हैं मैं क्या करूंगा एकको
लूंगा एकको करूंगा देन उसके बाद मैं क्या
क्या कैलकुलेशन परफॉर्म करने वा कैलकुलेशन
परफॉर्म करने के लिए आपको पता है
अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन का आपको यूज करना है
ये आपका अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन स्पेस देन अब
मैं यूज करने वाला हूं आपका बेसिक
कैलकुलेट सबसे पहले मुझे क्या करना है कि
सबक्स हो एडिशन हो तो मैं क्या करूंगा जो
फर्स्ट लाइन कमांड लाइन आर्गुमेंट मेरा
क्या रहेगा ऑपरेटर रहेगा कोई दिक्कत नहीं
मैं क्या करता हूं डॉलर यूज करूंगा कर्ली
ब्रेप यहां पर मैं क्या लिखूंगा मैं यहां
पर लिखूंगा सेकंड मैं यहां पर क्या लूंगा
सेकंड कमांड लाइन आर्गुमेंट लूंगा देन डैश
उसके बाद जीरो बाय डिफॉल्ट मैं यहां
वैल्यू ले रहा हूं यहां वैल्यू जो मैं ले
रहा हूं डिफॉल्ट जीरो ले रहा हूं क्यों
अगर मैंने कोई भी एडिशन किया है सबै क्शन
किया है अगर यूजर्स ने वहां पर एमटी छोड़
दिया अगर यहां पर कुछ भी कोई भी वैल्यू
नहीं दी तो ये बाय डिफॉल्ट वहां पर क्या
लेगा जीरो लेगा जिससे आपकी स्पीड पर कोई
भी इफेक्ट नहीं पड़ने वाला उसके बाद आप
क्या कर रहे हो देन उसके बाद आप क्या
एडिशन करना चाहते हो सबट क्शन करना चाहते
हो ओबवियसली तो अब मैं यहां क्या करने
वाला हूं डॉलर उसके बाद वन की वैल्यू लेने
वाला हू डॉलर वन क्या है आपका फर्स्ट
कमांड लाइन आर्गुमेंट होगा देन इसी प्रकार
से मैं अगर फ उसके बाद क्या कर डॉलर करली
बेसस और ओपन क्लोज देन उसके बाद थ्री उसके
बाद फिर से ड जीरो देन उसी बाद डॉलर वन
फिर से सबक्स एडिशन सबको मुझे क्या क्या
करना जितने भी कमांड लाइन आर्गुमेंट देगा
फर्स्ट कमांड लाइन आर्गुमेंट के अलावा व
सभी को क्या करना है जो फर्स्ट कमंडला
आर्गुमेंट में आपको ऑपरेशन परफॉर्म करने
के लिए बोला गया एडिशन सक्शन वो सबके ऊपर
परफॉर्म होना चाहिए तो ये रहा चलो हम करते
हैं उसके
बाद
डॉलर मुझे ऊपर से 10 तक ही जाना है मुझे
इससे ज्यादा जाना नहीं है डलर करली बेस
ओपन क्लोज देन उसके अंदर क्या करता हूं
फोर उसके बाद ये देन उसके बाद जीरो एक
मिनट कश जीरो उसके बाद
डॉलर वन देन उसके बाद फिर से मैं डॉलर ओपन
कर लि उसके बाद फाइ उसके बाद ये देन उसके
बाद ड जीरो देन उसके बाद डॉलर
फर्स्ट पलाइन आर्गुमेंट तरीके से हम क्या
करते अपनी स्कप को फाइनली पूरी कर देखो
वैसे लेंथ बन रही है लेकिन डोंट चीज की
तरफ आगे बढ़ेंगे तो यह चीज हमारी ऑटोमेटिक
कम होती आ जाएगी डलर वन
देन ओपन कर लिए क्लोज उसके बाद सेन देन य
जीरो उसके बाद डॉलर न
देन कट कॉपी पेस्ट मैं कर सकता लेकिन आप
चीज समझ में आनी चाहिए ए उसके बाद क्योंकि
एथ कमांड लाइन आर्गुमेंट उसके बाद जीरो
देन डॉलर वन आपको पता है क्या है एडिशन
सबक्स देन आपका क्या मैंने क्या दिया उसके
बाद डॉलर वन
देन डॉलर पले ओपन उसके बाद
नाइन जीरो उसके बाद
डॉलर वन उसके बाद डॉलर केलिए ओपन क्लोज
देन उसके बाद मैं इसके अंदर क्या दे रहा
हूं अभी तक नाइन मैंने कितना किया अभी
तक ओके नाइन 10 लास्ट मेरा 10 उसके बाद ये
रहा अब मैं इसको क्या करता हूं अभ ट एंटर
ये मेरी पूरी कमांड लाइन यह मेरी पूरी
कमांड मैंने आपको बना दी अब मैं क्या करता
इसको कंट्रोल एस करता हूं एक बार उसके बाद
कंट्रोल एक्स देखता हूं क्या ये एज इट इज
काम करे जैसा मैं चाहता हूं सीच मोड उसके
बाद परमिशन मुझे पता आपको पता कौन सी देनी
है 744 देनी है उसके बाद आपका क्या है
कैलकुलेटर कैलकुलेटर ड एच कर दिया देन मैं
शु बात करता हूं उसके बाद कैलकुलेटर ड एस
अब मुझे इसको फर्स्ट कमांड लाइन आर्गुमेंट
क्या देना आपको पता है फर्स्ट कमांड ला आट
ऑपरेशन देना है तो मैं क्या क चाहता हूं
एडिशन करना चाहता हूं देन उसके बाद मैं
किसका एडिशन करना चाहता हूं 7 स्पेस ना
स्पेस 5 इन तीन का एडिशन परफॉर्म करना
चाहता हूं और ट एंटर किया अभी यहां पर 21
आ गया अब अगर मैं आपको स्क्रिप्ट समझाऊं
तो कैसे काम की एजाम इसके सामने साथ
दिखाता हूं ये आया आपका से उसने फिर यहां
पर लिखा प्लस उसके बाद नाइन लिखा फिर उसके
बाद प्लस लिखा उसके बाद उसने फाइव लिखा
उसके बाद प्लस लिखा फाइ लिखा क्योंकि उसने
यहीं पर खत्म नहीं कर दिया क्योंकि उसमें
हमने कितने आर्गुमेंट दिए हैं 10 तक दिए
है ना प्लस उसके बाद नेक्स्ट इसके बाद
हमने कोई वैल्यू दी ना 1 2 3 4 के बाद तो
वैल्यू नहीं दी तो इसने क्या कर दिया जीरो
कर दिया उसके बाद क्या करया प्लस प्लस
उसके बाद फिर इसने जीरो लिया और ऐसे ही है
प्लस फ उसके बाद जीरो फिर प्लस फिर उसके
बाद जीरो उसके बाद प्लस फिर उसके बाद जीरो
इस तरीके से इसने क्या दस् तक
लिए थ फोर फ स से 8 ना और वन मोर इस तरीके
सेने इसको परफॉर्म किया है और हिट एंटर तब
उसने उसको परफॉर्म किया और उसकी जो वैल्यू
आई 21 आई है इस तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते
हो य पर जो वैल्यू है य पर क्या कर सकते
माइनस भी कर सकते हो अगर आप चाहो तो इसको
माइनस भी कर सकते हो तो इस तरीके से
परफॉर्म कर दे आपको आउटपुट शो करके दिखा
देगा यहा अगर मैं य पर क्या करता हूं
ना उसके बाद फ उसके बाद
टटर अभी आपके सामने आउटपुट में दो आ गया
इस तरीके से आपने क्या कर अपने स्क्रिप्ट
को सक्सेसफुली क्रिएट कर लिया तो यह थी एक
बेसिक स्क्रिप्ट बहुत ही बेसिक कैलकुलेशन
स्क्रिप्ट लेकिन क्या है थोड़ी सी क्या
होगी आपकी इसका जो कोड आपने जो लिखा थोड़ा
सा बड़ा लिखा है लेकिन इसमें कुछ भी नहीं
था इतना खास इस कोड में कुछ भी नहीं था
अगर किसी को स्क्रीनशॉट लेना है कि हमने
इसको कैसे परफॉर्म किया ये नहीं यह नहीं
था ये नहीं था कंट्रोल
एक् कंट्रोल ये नहीं था ये नहीं था यह था
ये यह रहा यह वो कोड लिखा था इससे ज्यादा
इसमें कुछ नहीं है सिंटेक्स आपका सिंपली
यूज किया जो असाइनमेंट हमें परफॉर्म करने
के लिए बोला गया था यह था कि आपको बेसिकली
एक ऑपरेटर लेना है उसके ऊपर बाकी सबको सम
करना है तो बिल्कुल ही बेसिक स्क्रिप्ट थी
इस तरीके से हमने स्क्रिप्ट को लिखा
नेक्स्ट हम जो हमारा टॉपिक पढ़ते हैं वो
हमारा जो टॉपिक है पढ़ने वाले हैं वो है
आपका का एक बार मुझे जितने भी लोग हैं तो
प्लीज ये बता दीजिए चैट में कि सबको समझ
में आ रहा है या नहीं आ रहा यस या नो या
किसी को इसमें कोई डाउट है स्टिल कुछ
पूछना चाहते हो किसी को लगता है कि इसमें
किसी कोई सवाल है तो वो मुझसे पूछ सकता है
अभी क्लास के आपके लिए मैं भी आपके चैट
सेशन देख रहा हूं एक बार जल्दी से बता
दीजिए यस या नो बता दीजिए कि सबको समझ में
आ रहा नहीं आ
रहा नोबडी विल रिप्लाई मी
ओके हम बात करते हैं नेक्स्ट अभी जो टॉपिक
पढ़ने वाले हम स्पेशल पैरामीटर्स के बारे
में पढ़ने वाले पढ़ने वाले स्पेशल
पैरामीटर्स के बारे में अ स्पेशल
पैरामीटर्स होते क्या है पने वाले हम यह
क्या है हमारा स्पेशल
पैरामीटर्स स्क्रीन को क्लियर कर देता
हूं मैं आपको दिखाता हूं स्पेशल
पैरामीटर स्पेशल
पैरामीटर अब ये स्पेशल पैरामीटर्स होते
देखो स्पेशल पैरामीटर वे होते
हैं जिनको बेस कुछ स्पेशल मीनिंग देती है
बसव स्पेशल मीनिंग मैं इस इसकी डेफिनेशन
आपके सामने लिखू तो आपको समझ में आ जाएगी
ऑटोमेटिक स्पेशल
पैरामीटर्स
पैरामीटर्स मीटर्स ट
बेस गिव्स
स्पेशल
मीनिंग मतलब क्या है कि स्पेशल पैरामीटर्स
वो होते हैं जो बेस में कुछ स्पेशल मीनिंग
आप अपने आपको को देते हैं देखो ये क्या है
कुछ सिमिलर कांसेप्ट आपका सेल वेरिएबल की
तरह जो आपने सेल वेरिएबल का कांसेप्ट पढ़ा
था लास्ट में बिल्कुल उसी की तरह सिमिलर
कांसेप्ट है लेकिन एक की डिफरेंस यही है
कि सेल वेरिएबल की वैल्यू को आप मैनुअली
चेंज कर सकते हैं लेकिन स्पेशल पैरामीटर्स
की वैल्यू को आप चेंज नहीं कर सकते उनकी
वैल्यू
फिक्स रहती है फिक्स का भी मतलब मैं आपको
एक चीज बताता हूं एक स्पेशल थिंग होती है
स्पेशल पैरामीटर की स्पेशलिटी क्या है व
भी आपके सामने लिख देता हूं की
य
द थिंग
ट मेक्स
ए
स्पेशल
पैरामीटर
स्पेशल इ
ट इ
ट ओके इ
ट
द
वैल्यू ऑफ
ए स्ल ऑफ
ए ऑ
स्पेशल
पैरामीटर पटर
इज
कैलकुलेटेड इ कैलकुलेटेड फॉर
अस बेस्ड
ऑन बेस्ड
ऑन व्ट इज
हैपनिंग हैपनिंग और जज हैपन जज
हैपन इन
द करंट स्क्रिप्ट इन द करंट स्कप बेसिक
मतलब क्या है देखो स्पेशल पैरामीटर स्पेशल
वो चीज बनाती है क्योंकि इसकी जो जो
वैल्यू है ना वो कोई हम उसको फिक्स नहीं
बोल सकते इसकी वैल्यू क्या करती है वो
अकॉर्डिंग टू सिचुएशन रिएक्ट करती है जैसे
कि आपकी स्क्रिप्ट में क्या हो गया या
क्या चल रहा है उसके बेसिस प इनकी वैल्यू
क्या करती है वरी करती रहती है बट इनकी
वैल्यू को आप चेंज नहीं कर सकते इनकी
वैल्यू को क्या नहीं कर सकते आप चेंज नहीं
कर सकते ओके इनकी वैल्यू को आप चेंज नहीं
कर सकते तो सबसे पहले और एक और चीज है कि
देखो जब आप इनकी वैल्यू को चेंज कर ही
नहीं सकते ऊपर से क्या कि आपके काफी काफी
शॉर्टकट क्रिएट करने के काम आती है ये
स्पेशल पैरामीटर्स है तो हम काफी
कॉन्फिडेंस के साथ कह सकते हैं इनकी जो
वैल्यू होगी स्पेशल पैरामीटर्स की वो
एक्यूरेट होगी क्योंकि इनकी वैल्यू को आप
किसी भी हाल में कैसे भी चेंज नहीं कर
सकते सबसे पहला जो स्पेशल पैरामीटर है
जिसकी हम बात करने वाले हैं सबसे पहला
स्पेशल पैरामीटर है वो हम बात करें
डॉलर डॉलर रेट डॉलर हैज डॉलर
हैज एक मिनट यार तो सबसे पहले जो सबसे
पहले हम स्पेशल पैरामीटर हम पढ़ने वाले
हैं वो आपका है
डॉलर डॉलर और हैज सबसे
पहले ओके
आर तो सबसे पहला पटर आपका डॉलर हैज मैं
आपको दिखा देता हूं ये रहा इसको हम ऐसे
लिखते
हैं कैसे लिखू
रुको रुको स्कन पर
चलते य सबसे पहले स्पेशल पैरामीटर आपका य
है
डॉलर डॉलर और जज यह सबसे पहले आपका स्पेशल
पैरामीटर य आपका स्पेशल पैरामीटर है डलर य
क्या करता है देखो इसके बारे में लिख आपको
इसके बार में लिखवाता
हूं इट इज ए
स्पेशल स्पेशल
पैरामीटर जो एक्सपेंड्स
य एक् एक्सपेंड्स
टू
द नंबर
ऑफ
पोजीशनल
पैरामीटर्स पैरामीटर ट
हैव बीन
प्रोवाइडेड
प्रोवाइडेड टू द
स्क्रिप्ट अगर आप यह कैलकुलेट करना चाहते
हैं कि आपने अपने स्क्रिप्ट में कितने
नंबर ऑफ पोजीशनल पैरामीटर्स दिए हैं या
कितने नंबर कमांड ला आर्गुमेंट प्रोवाइड
किए कितने नंबर ऑ पोजीशन पैरामीटर आपने
दिए हुए अपने स्क्रिप्ट को अगर वो वैल्यू
कैलकुलेट करना चाते हो इसके लिए आप यूज
करोगे डॉलर है का अगर इसका मैं अगर एक
प्रैक्टिकल एग्जांपल दिखाता हूं आपको य
रहा अभी मैंने स्क्रिप्ट कट स्क्रिप्ट थ
मेरी कौन सी स्क्रिप्ट थी ये
रहा रुको यार क्या इ है
इसको
यस एल ये रहा पोजीशन स्कप पोशन स्क्रिप
मेरी एक ननो किया मैंने उसके बाद
पोजीशनल य अगर मैं इसके एंड में अगर एकको
कर देता हूं एकको और उसके बाद मैं क्या
करता हूं डॉलर एक को डॉलर और हैज कर देता
हूं अगर मैं ऐसा लिख देता हूं देन कंट्रोल
एस और एक्स कर देता हूं और स्क्रिप्ट को
मैं क्या करता हूं रन करता हूं ज
स्क्रिप्ट को मैं रन करता अरे यार मेरे
बहुत प्रॉब्लम आ रहा है कीबोर्ड इशू आ रहा
है एम कीड इशू आ
रहा इसके बाद अगर मैं इसको क्या करता
रन प स्किप इस तरीके से मैं इसको रन कर
देता हूं ये देखो और ट एंड करता हूं देखो
आपको एंड में इसने क्या कर दिया कि माय
नेम सचिन इसके एंड में टोटल 11 लिख के दे
दिया क्योंकि हमने टोटल इसमें कितने
आर्गुमेंट दिए हैं 11 दिया अगर मैं इसको
ना और जीरो और दे देता हिट एंटर तब ये
दिखाता आपको कि आपने इस जो स्क्रिप्ट में
आपने जो आर्गुमेंट दिए हैं नंबर ऑफ पोजीशन
पैरामीटर्स दिए हैं य वो 13 है और इनकी जो
जिस हिसाब से आपने वैल्यू को फैच किया जो
टास्क परफॉर्म करना वो आपकी स्क्रीन प शो
कर रहा है तो डोलर है क्या करता है आपके
जो पोजीशन पैरामीटर्स की वैल्यू को टोटल
नबर पो पैटर की वैल्यू कैलकुलेट कर कितने
टोटल नंबर ऑ पोशन पैरामीटर आपने अपने
स्क्रिप्ट को मेंशन किए हैं ये इस वैल्यू
को शो करता है उसके बाद जो नेक्स्ट आता है
आपका एक डॉलर जीरो आता है जो नेक्स्ट आपका
आता है वो डॉलर जीरो आता है ये रहा अब बात
करें जो येय आता है डॉलर जीरो य आता अब ये
क्या करता है देखो डॉलर जीरो की बात कर
डॉलर जीरो क्या करता है ये काफी क्या
थोड़ा सा आपका आप बोलोगे थोड़ा यर्ड है ये
यड कैसे है ना यह बिल्कुल फ्लेक्सिबल है
मतलब कि इसको जहां पर यूज करते हैं ना
उसके हिसाब से रिजल्ट को आपके सामने शो
करता है अगर मैंने इसको टर्मिनल प यूज
किया तो आपके क्या करता है कि जो करंट सेल
है उसको एक्सपेंड कर देया उसकी वैल्यू को
अगर मुझे किसी स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर इसको यूज
किया तो स्क्रिप्ट के नाम के साथ इसको
एक्सपेंड कर देगा उसका नाम शो कर दिया फॉर
एग्जांपल मैं क्या करता हूं अगर मैंने एको
किया और डॉलर यहां पर जीरो कर दिया मैंने
इसने क्या कर दिया ये रहा जस सेल का नाम
दे दिया अगर मैं इसको क्या करता किसी
स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर मेंशन करता फॉर
एग्जांपल मेरी ये स्क्रिप्ट है ये रहा ननो
एस और मैं इसको क्या कर देता इधर ये रहा
इसकी वैल्यू में डॉलर एकको इसकी हैज की
जगह में जीरो कर देता हूं और हिट एंटर कर
देता हूं कंट्रोल एस और एक्स कर देता हूं
अब देखना ये रहा हिट एंटर अभी देखो लास्ट
में इसने क्या लिख दिया डॉट पोजीशन मतलब य
क्या थोड़ा सा वड लगता है लेकिन क्या है
ना ये काफी हेल्पफुल होता है खास कर की उन
जगह पर जब आप क्या चाहते हो कि आपने कोई
स्क्रिप्ट को बनाया लेकिन आपको जो यूजर्स
है उसको नहीं पता स्क्रिप्ट को कैसे यूज
करना है अगर धोखे से उसने आपकी स्क्रिप्ट
में कुछ फ्लैग मेंशन भूल गया और कुछ करना
कर गया जिसकी वजह से क्या एरर क्रिएट होगी
तो आप अपनी स्क्रिप्ट में एक एरर मैसेज
में ये बताना चाहता हूं कि भैया आपको कैसे
यूज करनी है कि स्क्रिप्ट का नाम उसके बाद
क्या-क्या आर्गुमेंट आपके मैंडेटरी हो
क्या-क्या ऑप्शनल आप दे सकते हो आपने हर
बार एक हेल्प फाइल हमेशा मिलती है ना एक
यूसेज आता है ना जब भी आप कोई भी
स्क्रिप्ट को गलत तरीके से रन करते तो
वहां पर क्या आपको एक यूसेज देखने को
मिलता है तो यही चीज है वो कट करने के लिए
काम आता है और इनका जो कॉमिनेशन है ना
इसका जो डॉलर हैज का और डॉलर जीरो का काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग है कैसे इंटरेस्टिंग कैसे है
क्योंकि इनकी हेल्प से क्या किया इस इस
तरीके जो एक एक्साइटिंग स्क्रिप्ट बना
सकते हो जैसे कि फॉर एग्जांपल मैं आपको
दिखाता हूं नो
स्पेशल स्पेशल स्क्रिप्ट एस सी आर आई पीटी
स्क्रिप्ट डॉट एसएस मैंने किया उसके बाद
हिट एंटर कर दिया देन मैं सी बै सी बैंग
लाइन मेंशन करता ह यहां पर बिन और बैस बिन
और बैस उसके बाद मैं आपको क्या है जो अभी
जो लिख रहा हूं अगर आपको समझ में भी नहीं
आया डोंट वरी नेक्स्ट क्लास में आपको पता
चलता है मैं इफ कंडीशन के साथ लिख रहा हूं
और कंडीशन मेंशन कर रहा हूं मैं स्पेसिफाई
कर रहा हूं इसके अंदर वो कंडीशन क्या
रहेगी देखते
है य रहा जो कंडीशन है कि इफ डॉलर हैज
डॉलर हैज मतलब आपको काउंट करना है कि जो
नंबर लाइन ऑफ आर्गुमेंट है वो अगर नॉट
इक्वल मतलब नॉट इक्वल टूटू अगर वो दो नहीं
है अगर नॉट इक्वल टूटू नहीं है तो आपको
क्या करना
है नॉट इक्वल टूटू देन य इसका सिंटेक्स
लिखने का देन कंडीशन आपको क्या करना है
एक क्या करना
है
यू
डन यू डन
एंटर एंटर एगजैक्टली
एटली टू पैरामीटर्स पैरामीटर्स एगजैक्टली
टू पैरामीटर्स ये इस तरीके से मैंने इसको
लिखा देन नेक्स्ट इसमें क्या किया मैंने
एक फिर लिखा मैंने एक देन मैं आपको यूसेज
दिखा कि आपको किस तरीके से यूज करना है
इसको यूसेज आपको लिखना है यूसेज ऐसे उसके
बाद डॉलर जीरो क् यहां पर डॉलर जीरो मेंशन
करोगे देन आपको लिखना है यहां पर यहां पर
नाम देना फाइल वन देन उसके बाद आपको देखने
को मिलता है हमेशा उसके बाद फाइल टू देन
उसको क्लोज किया करली ब्रेसस के अंदर कर
दिया देन उसके बाद मैं इसको स्टेट दे देता
हूं एग्जिट स्टेट इसका क्या दिया मैंने वन
जब एरर आएगी तो ऐसे ही है और उसके बाद
इसको क्लोज कर दिया इसके अलावा मैं कोई
कंडीशन दे ही नहीं रहा हूं उसको कंट्रोल s
और एक्स दिया मैंने अब मैं इसको एक परमिशन
मेंशन करर हूं सीच मोड देन इसको 744
परमिशन मैंने मेंशन किया ओके 744 देन
स्पेशल पैरामीटर एक्स अब इसको हम क्या
करते हैं रन करते हैं उसके बाद क्या है
स्पेशल प स्पेशल डॉ उसके बाद मैं दो
आर्गुमेंट दे देता हूं पहला आर्गुमेंट
मैंने क्या दिया कि मैंने लिखा वन और टू
दे दिया हिट एंटर अभी कुछ नहीं हुआ
क्योंकि हमने इसके लिए कोई कोड लिखा नहीं
था फॉर एग्जांपल मैंने इसके अंदर दो
आर्गुमेंट मेंशन नहीं किए मैंने एक ही
आर्गुमेंट मेंशन किया हिट एंटर कर दिया अब
इसने क्या बोला यू डन एंटर एगजैक्टली टू
पैरामीटर आपने दो पैरामीटर एंटर नहीं किए
अगर आपको स्क्रिप्ट को यूज करना है तो
आपका यूसेज कैसे है ये रहा देखो स्पेशल
पैरामीटर स्क्रिप्ट का नाम फाइल वन फाइल
टू आप लोगों को लगता है कि नहीं ये इसके
स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर नहीं अगर मैं चाहूं तो
एक काम कर देता ह अगर आपको समझ में तो
देखो मूव किया मैंने जो आपकी स्पेशल एसस
उसको मैंने इसी टर्मिनल के अंदर मैंने
लिखा इसमें कि स्पेशल को वेरी स्पेशल एस
पी ई सी आई ए स्पेशल स्क्रिप्ट एस सी आर
आई प स्क्रिप्ट डट एस एच ट एंटर कर दिया
देन अगर मैं इसको क्या करता एग्जीक्यूट
करता हूं वेरी स्पेशल के नाम से फ और उसके
बाद भी मैं आर्गुमेंट एक ही दिया मैंने ट
एंटर कर दिया तब भी इसने क्या लिखा यू ड
नट एंटर दो एगजैक्टली उसके बाद क्या यूसेज
में क्या लिखा अबकी बार प्रेजेंट जो
स्क्रिप्ट का नाम था उसके साथ उसके बाद
आपने क्या लिखा फाइल वन फाइल टू आपको ऐसे
आर्गुमेंट देने हैं तभी आपके कमांड काम
करेगी अदर वाइज ये आपके कमांड है या जो
आपके स्क्रिप्ट है काम नहीं करेंगे इस
तरीके से आप क्या करते हो अभी तक जितने भी
आप कमांड्स यूज करते आए हो जितने भी टूल्स
यूज करते आए हो वो उसी तरीके से आपको
देखने को मिलता है कई बार आप किसी भी
नए-नए टूल के साथ जब आप काम कर रहे हो तो
आपको नहीं समझ में आता और कुछ ना कुछ गलती
कर दे तो उसका य जो यूसेज का जो एक इंडिग
होती है जो एरर है वो इस तरीके से आपको
देखने को मिलती है तो आप इस तरीके से खुद
भी डिजाइन कर सकते हो तो स्पेशल
पैरामीटर्स की दो स्पेशल चीजें थी जो एक
डॉलर जीरो है डॉलर हैज है इसके अंदर दो दो
से चार स्पेशल पैरामीटर्स और बची है लेकिन
उसमें टाइम लगेगा तो आज का सेशन यहीं पर
एंड करते हैं कंटिन्यू हम नेक्स्ट सेशन
में करेंगे उन दो उन दो के बारे में
कौन-कौन सा दो हैय एक तो डॉलर बाद में
बताऊंगा मैं चलो अभी नहीं बताऊंगा उसके
बेसिस पर फिर हम एक काम करेंगे आपको मैं
असाइनमेंट दूंगा वो असाइनमेंट आप लोगों को
करना उसके बाद नेक्स्ट क्लास में उसको हम
डिस्कस करेंगे और नया टॉपिक स्टार्ट
करेंगे तो आज का सेशन हम इधर ही एंड करते
हैं आप लोगों के लिए दो मिनट डाउट सेशन है
तो कोई भी अगर चैट में अपने डाउट पूछना
पूछना चाहता तो पूछ सकता
है
ब
हम
चलो फर सेशन एंड करते
हैं बाय बाय सी यू